Hi everyone.
Welcome to this week's Google+
platform office hours.
This week, I'm sitting at a
table because we're going to
be doing some live coding.
We're going to be writing a
jQuery plug-in that uses the
JavaScript client library to
pull activity from your
Google+ page or your profile
and insert it
into your web page.
And we're doing this
in a jQuery
plug-in by popular demand.
I sent out a little survey.
So thanks for your feedback
if you voted on that.
So before I dive into the--
oh, and then after that, I
will be fielding your questions
that you've asked on
the Google+ platform page.
Oh, I guess I should introduce
myself first. Hi,
I'm Jennifer Murphy.
I'm a developer programs
engineer here at Google.
And what I do is, I help you
guys all build cool stuff
using the Google+ API.
It's like the stuff we're going
to be working on today.
But yeah, not limited just
to the REST APIs.
Feel free to ask questions
about hangouts apps, the
plug-ins or anything
else that's part
of the Google+ platform.
OK, well, let's see what we're
going to be writing today.
Dive right into the content.
So, let me show you a
quick demo of what
we're going to build.
Built it last night, and
then I put it into my
personal web page.
So, switching over to screen
sharing, you can see this on
the left side, underneath the
badge, there's a little box
that shows recent activity.
And that's showing
recent activity
from my Google+ profile.
And that's kind of cool on my
hub page to be able to show
people what I've been
up to recently.
And this is implemented with the
jQuery plug-in that we'll
be building.
So when you're done going
through this demo, you'll be
able to put something like
that on your web page.
So let's switch over, and gonna
show you a little bit of
the design behind what
we're building.
So to accomplish that using
a jQuery plug-in, there's
actually a few different
pieces that go into it.
We have our index HTML file,
which is the web page itself.
And it's calling out
to a couple things.
First of all, we're
going to need to
include the jQuery library.
That's what we need to
wire up the plug-ins
and do all that stuff.
We have our plug-in itself,
which will then be making use
of the Google API JavaScript
client library.
And that will then be making
calls to the Google+ REST APIs
to fetch our activities.
And once it's fetched our
activities, the data kind of
goes back up the whole
stack and then
renders in our HTML document.
So there's a lot of pieces
involved, but each one of
those pieces is actually
pretty simple.
So we'll go through them one at
a time as we implement it.
Time to dive into the code.
Screen share again, switching
screens to my IDE, where we'll
be doing the coding.
We'll make it a little smaller
so it's easier for you to see
on the web page.
So what do we have open?
I mentioned that there's an HTML
file, which is what we
have open right now, and the
jQuery plug-in are the two
files we're going to be editing
during this live
coding session.
Let's take a look at the HTML
file first. It's a skeleton.
It looks a lot like you
would expect a lot of
jQuery demos to look.
We have all of our libraries
loaded that
were going to need.
We have jQuery itself, loaded
off of GoogleAPIs.com because
CDMI's libraries are great.
They're fast and easy to use.
We have our plug-in which is
right now [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
plug-in, which I'll be going
through in a moment.
And we also have the Google
JavaScript client library, and
it's configured such
that when it
loads, it calls a function--
gapi.Ready().
And this is where we'll be
wiring up everything because
we need the client library to be
fully loaded before we can
invoke our plug-in.
Scrolling going down the page,
there's a couple of divs--
recent-activity and
recent-activity-2.
So these are places where we're
going to be inserting
the activity into the pages
in the jQuery plug-in.
So if you've done jQuery before
this should look pretty
straightforward.
Next, let's take a look
at the plug-in.
Here is an empty plug-in.
It's kind of a skeleton that
I use to build a lot of my
jQuery plug-ins.
If you've done plug-in
development in jQuery before,
this should look pretty
familiar.
But you can ignore a lot of
it if you haven't done the
development.
Up on the top-- a lot
of it's just kind
of boilerplate jQuery.
But near the top, there's
a settings area.
And this is where any
configuration for our plug-in,
all of the defaults
will be set.
Then there's more boilerplate
name-spacing.
And the primary iterator
that goes through and--
so that if you're operator of a
collection of objects, it'll
work on all of them
And then finally doStuff.
This is where we'll actually
be implementing our stuff.
And then the other file I have
open is nothing more than the
JavaScript client
library sample.
So I just went to the
documentation, grabbed the
sample code right out of
the wiki page, and
pasted it into here.
And I did that because writing
code from scratch, especially
the first time, can be
pretty challenging.
So I usually will work
samples if I can.
So what we're going to be doing,
is we're probably going
to be copying a lot of the code
out of the sample, and
then modifying it to
fit our needs.
OK, we've seen what
we have opened.
Let's get into the code.
So the first thing we should
do is probably wire stuff
together because we have our
HTML file, but the plug-in is
not actually being called yet.
And we're going to be calling
the plug-in from gapi.ready().
This is a little bit different
than a lot of jQuery you
write, because you usually
probably trigger your jQuery
from the onload of the document
itself, like the ready.
But we need all of the
pieces to be ready.
In addition to the document,
we need that the JavaScript
client library to be ready.
So that's why we're using
a different function
to line it all up.
We're going to be
operating below.
What we're going to do first is,
we're going to replace the
recent activity div with
some activities.
So let's see what we're going to
write here for the jQuery.
We're going to do a selector
for the recent activity,
except spelled right.
And that's going to use your
query to grab that recent
activity div. And then we're
going to call our plug-in,
which is just the name of the
function in the plug-in.
And then we're going
to pass in any
configuration that we want.
This is where we have to do
a little bit of thinking.
So for the rest API to be able
to call our activity to get
access to our public
activity, we need a
minimum of two fields.
We need an API key, which you
can get by going to the API
Council and registering a
new project, which is--
I covered in a previous
video, which I'll link
to in the show notes.
So we're going to need an API
key at the minimum, and we're
also going to need to know the
ID of the profiler page from
which we're getting
our activities.
So userId.
And I've already done these, so
I'll just paste in values.
Here's an API key, and here is
the userId of my profile on
Google+, my personal profile.
So this ID you can either get
by looking at the page and
copying it out of the URL.
Or you can access
it using the API
Explorer to get the profile.
There's a lot of ways to get it,
which is also covered in
another video that I'll link
to in the show notes.
But, once we have both of these
values in, we're pretty
much wired up in terms of the
content that we have to add to
the HTML file.
This is a good starting
point for where
we're going to be going.
So switching over to the
plug-in, you see the name we
chose in the HTML files
coincidentally matches the
name of our plug-in, so it's
going to be called--
and let's just dive into
the doStuff part.
So does doStuff mean
for this plug-in?
There's a few different things
we're going to be doing.
The first thing we're going
to be doing is--
pull out my notes--
we're going to be creating
a new JavaScript client.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So we'll create a JavaScript
client.
We'll tell it what APIs are
going to be calling.
We'll set all the configuration
for it.
Then we're going to be fetching
our activity.
And finally we'll be rendering
it into the page.
Seems pretty straightforward,
and it will be.
So, first, let's create
our JavaScript client.
This is where we're going to be
invoking the sample that I
copied from the wiki page.
Reading through this sample,
it's pretty short.
It's only 30 lines of code.
We can see that it already
shows us how to create a
client library during
the load function.
So gapi.client.load is
what we need to run.
So let's just copy that fix
it into our plug-in.
The only differences are, our
API key is coming from the
settings that were passed into
the plug-in when we call it
settings at API key.
And we're calling
a different API.
The sample from the wiki page
uses the URL shortener.
We're going to be calling
the Plus API.
And it calls a makeRequest
function.
We can just put a function
in line here.
So now what will happen is, we
set our API key and we have a
client library all set up.
Oops.
Let's now, from within this
function we'll fetch the
activity, and then render
it into our page.
So it's not out activity,
it's our activity.
So we now need to learn, now
that we have a client library
created, we need to actually get
the data, make the call.
Let's lean back on our sample
again to see how it did it.
It ran this makeRequest
function,
which is right up here.
And you can see that it creates
a request object and
then executes it.
Create a new request
object has the
method description here.
So it's using the URL shortener
to do a url.get.
We can copy this and
modify it too.
So we'll just copy this out,
paste it in here, and modify
it to fit our needs.
So we're going to be doing
plus, or actually
client.plus.activities.list. And
you're probably wondering
how I knew those names
for this function.
These are the names of the
functions for the REST APIs,
so you can either go to the
reference docs to look them
up, or I usually use the API
Explorer Which I'll link in
the show notes.
The identifiers and the API
Explorer, the names of the
methods and the names
of the APIs,
actually match these exactly.
So you can copy and paste right
into here, which is what
I did while I was
developing it.
So now that we've created
a rest request that gets
activities, or that lists our
activities, we need to pass in
those two critical parameters
at the very least. So let's
pass in our API key.
Or actually, the key, we already
configured above.
We need to pass in our userId.
Sorry.
Here we go.
And that's also going to come
from the settings because we
passed it in when we created
the plug-in, or when we
invoked the plug-in from
our HTML file.
There are a couple other
required parameters, which you
can see from the reference docs,
or from-- or actually,
there is one other required
parameter.
As you can see from the
reference docs, or the API
Explorer, we need to specify a
collection, which is a string.
And there's only one valid
option, which is "Public." And
we should probably also specify
one of the optional
parameters.
By default this API returns 10
activities, which could take
up a lot of space.
So let's specify max
results value.
And let's do 5 for now.
So now that we've created our
request with all of the
required parameters, and one
of the optional parameters,
we'll execute it.
And the function in the
sample, they just
appended the results.
So that's where we'll be doing
our rendering stuff.
But we don't need to call an
appendResults function, which
is the function defined
in that sample.
We'll just put the
rendering here.
So, at this step, what I'll
usually do is log the response
object and take a look at what
the response object looks like
in debugging tools like the
Chrome debug tools or Firebug
or something like that.
And it's just an object that
contains a bunch of attributes
about the activities.
So, I'll usually kind of click
around to see what kind of
information I want, where it
exists in that big old object,
and then just do regular
HTML creation.
So rather than walk you through
all of that stuff,
which is pretty standard jQuery,
I'm going to grab a
copy of it.
And here we go.
jQuery-ized, a jQuery way of
creating a HTML element.
So what we're doing is, we're
taking that response object,
we're grabbing the items out of
it, which is a list of all
the activities in
that response.
And then we're taking-- we're
iterating through those
activities in the items list,
and we're pulling some
information out of it.
We're pulling the publish date,
the URL of the activity
on Google+, and the
content itself.
The object.content, which is the
full text of the activity.
And then we're creating an
unordered list that contains
the time stamp and then all
of the activity contents.
Then we take it and we appended
to this, which is
going to be inserting it inside
of the HTML element the
jQuery was called in, in this
case, our activities.
So that is all the
code, actually.
And we can see it in action.
You pull it up in
a web browser.
I'm going to switch back to my
camera for a while, while I
futz around with
screen sharing.
And there we go.
This is my activity loaded
from that plug-in.
Pretty cool, isn't it?
And if you're actually including
this in your web
page, there's probably a
bunch of other stuff
you'll want to do.
Pull my screen sharing.
Probably some other stuff
you'll want to do.
You'll probably want to do some
additional formatting on
the content that you're
rendering on your web page.
You probably don't want the
whole activity to be posted.
Or maybe you want to include
information about whether it
was a reshare, or if there was
an image attached, you may
want to render that image
within this widget.
That all kind of comes down to
the details of that last
section of the plug-in.
But it's really just
that simple.
And under 100 lines of code, and
we have a starting point
for implementing your way to--
to include your content on any
external web page, which is a
great way to show people where
you're active on the internet.
Cool, OK.
So the code for that is already
up [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
control.
I'll be linking to it
from the show notes.
So, you'll be able to go in
there and grab the code.
And especially when it's on air,
sometimes it's kind of
hard to see the signing window,
the text doesn't
render quite great.
So you'll be able to walk
through the code yourself.
You'll be able to drop a running
version into your
pages, and play with it and
all that cool stuff.
So, hope you have
fun with that.
So now that live coding is
through, let's answer some of
your questions.
So I'm going to pull up the page
and take a look at what
you guys have been discussing
well I've been yammering over
here about my code.
Cool.
Well, you had asked some
great questions
before the hangout started.
I'm going to start by answering
some of these.
So Jeffrey asked, are there
beta testing abilities for
account holders, including
business who have pages?
This is a great question.
It's always cool to stay ahead
of the curve, especially if
you are a publisher who has
included our publisher
widgets, our publisher plug-ins,
on your web pages.
For example, the +1 button
or the badge.
It's really important that
you stay a little bit
ahead of the curve.
And we actually have a program
specifically for the publisher
features for the plug-ins that
enable you to do this.
So what you can do is, there's
a form you can go to today.
You punch in your Google
account, or your Gmail
account, and then whenever
we're about to push new
features for the plug-ins,
you'll see them early, either
a few days early for small
changes, or maybe a couple
weeks early for larger changes
or new releases.
You'll see them when you're
logged into that account in
the new version, which allows
you to adjust all of your web
designs, potentially,
to new color schemes
and things like that.
We definitely listen to all the
feedback that comes from
that program, so I will share
that in the show notes.
But that is just for
the plug-ins.
We don't really have any beta
programs for other features of
the platform right now.
It's always something
we're investigating.
But I'll put a link to the
sign-up form for the publisher
preview in the show notes.
Thanks.
So, Hector asked, any news
on when the API will be
available, or when more desktop
features are coming to
mobile, like URL summaries
and image previews.
I have great news for you.
We have APIs already.
In fact, I just showed you
how to use some of them.
And the APIs are a lot more
broad then the REST APIs that
I just showed you.
In addition to the REST APIs,
which give you access to
public data on Google+, such
as posts, profiles, and
comments, you also have some
other really cool features.
We have the social plug-ins
that allow you to insert--
to link up your external sites
to Google+ via the +1 button
to enable sharing, via the
badge, so people know about
your presence on Google+.
Those are pretty powerful.
But my favorite right now, the
most important part in my
opinion, is the hangout apps,
which are a great way to write
interactive programs that run
within a hangout like the
hangout we're doing right now.
And they're a ton of fun.
There's a lot of really cool
stuff you can write.
And there's a lot of cool
apps out there already.
So, moving on.
Stephen asks about moderation
features in hangouts.
We're using hangouts
right now.
I'm definitely a big hangout
user, so I totally understand
why you want more moderation
features, especially if you're
using hangouts for things that
are beyond just a regular
informal meeting between
friends.
When you're using them for more
sophisticated purposes,
it will be really cool to have
moderation controls to be able
to kind of manage a hangout,
maybe schedule one ahead of
time, all that kind of stuff.
This is great feedback.
Unfortunately, this is probably
something we're not
going to implement initially as
a feature of the platform.
So I can't really talk to
it in a lot of detail.
It's something that we're going
to have to implement as
a core feature first.
So like all of the Google+
recommendations I get, I'd
like to ask you to please
do me a favor.
There's a send feedback link in
the lower corner of the web
page, depending on which
language you're in.
It's either the right
or left corner.
So click on the send feedback
link and send
this feedback to us.
We listen to this feedback.
It automatically gets routed
to the right team.
It may get aggregated.
But people are definitely
listening to the feedback.
And you may not get a response,
but someone's
definitely listening.
So please send details about
what kind of moderation
features you'd like to see
in hangouts via the
send feedback tool.
I'd really appreciate that.
Thanks.
And Danny asks, when can I have
hangouts on air, the very
feature you're watching
me on right now.
So hangouts on air is not ready
for prime time yet.
We're still in a testing phase,
and it's a big feature.
So we're taking our time to make
sure it's really polished
before we pass it out
to everyone else.
So please hang tight.
I don't really have a lot.
I don't know when it will be
available, and don't know when
we can roll it out
to more people.
But hang tight right now.
Keep an eye on the
Google+ blog.
When it's ready, you'll
definitely see news there.
And then you'll be
able to dig in.
Next stop is Fergin.
Fergin--
I hope I got your name right.
Hi Fergin.
We talked a little bit
last week too.
You mentioned that you were
having an issue where the
numbers on Google Analytics,
Google Webmaster Tools, and
your +1 button that describe
your social interactions were
a little bit out of sync,
or a lot out of sync.
We're still investigating
this.
And as you've noticed, the
count's gone up on the +1
button on your web page,
so we're continuing to
investigate this.
And I don't have a final answer
yet, which is why I
haven't responded to the issue
that you filed on the issue
tracker, which you mentioned
in your comment.
But I do have a little bit I can
tell you about, what we're
digging around in there
and finding.
Google Analytics takes a little
bit of a different
approach to social tracking then
Webmaster Tools and the
+1 button count itself.
Webmaster Tools and +1 button
count, the count on the button
itself, are really focused
on the +1 button.
So they're able to keep track
of when someone unclicks the
+1 button, or when a +1 is
excluded for some reason.
Google Analytics, on the other
hand, is a much more generic
social tracking tool.
It tracks +1s out of the box,
but you can pretty easily
configure it to track tweets,
you can configure track
Facebook likes, and pretty
much any other social
interaction via the JavaScript
hooks they provide.
And this is really powerful, but
as a result of it being a
very generic feature, it has a
little bit less insight into
exactly what it's tracking.
The gist of it is,
it tracks social
activities, and not +1s.
So, someone comes and un +1s a
page, Google Analytics isn't
going to reduce that count.
It only counts up because it's
a record of all the social
activities that have happened
historically.
So that's why Google Analytics
is usually going to register a
little bit higher, and
there is a bigger
discrepancy on your page.
So we're still investigating,
but I will respond to the
issue once we have
a final answer.
But I thought you would
appreciate an update, since
you were nice enough to
keep us up-to-date.
So, thanks a lot.
And that's all the questions I
saw that were posted before,
so bear with me as I dig through
the comments that have
been asked during the show.
So there's some questions
about the new
Google+ user interface.
It's still rolling out.
It's pretty cool.
I like it a lot.
And it's still rolling
out across, so you
may not see it yet.
Just hang tight, it'll
be there soon.
As with all of our releases,
a lot of these things go
gradually just because we want
to make sure it's rolling out
well before we keep pushing
it to everyone.
Michael Tucker mentions that it
can be a little tricky to
run a chat during a hang out,
and it can help to have an
extra person doing
production work.
And that's actually what
we're doing right now.
Julia is back in the camera
right now, making sure that my
audio levels are appropriate
and all that stuff.
And that's actually really
good advice.
If you're running hangout on
air, or if you're just doing
[? hyperfail ?] hangout at all
It helps to have someone who's
not on camera who is managing
and making sure all the data
flows right, and that the sound
levels are all good, and
can shoot a Nerf dart
at you when
you're talking too quietly.
So great advice.
We've learned that too,
and it helps so much.
Danny, you asked why
you couldn't join
the hangout at 11:30.
Because of the nature of the
hangout on air, we keep it a
little bit more limited
audience, just to make sure
that we can keep it focused.
But I definitely like to open
up these hangouts to
developers.
So if you have a question, when
you ask it on the thread,
just mention that you'd like
to ask it in person.
And then what will happen is,
we'll loop back with you, and
we'll communicate and arrange
all of the timing and stuff,
so you can join the
hangout in person.
And that goes for all
of you out there.
So if any of you has something
you'd like to discuss, on the
hangout on air, just ping us
ahead of time, whoever created
the hangout announcement.
And we'll talk to you, and see
if we can get you in here.
Because we always like talking
to developers in person via
the hangout.
It's so much better.
So there's a great question
in there from Fabio.
Hi, is it possible, when using
the activity search method,
for example, querying for a very
specific hashtag, to only
get the activities created
after a previous search?
So it sounds like you're trying
to build a continuous
feed of activities for
a specific hashtag.
Right now there's no way
to filter by date.
It's something that would
be really powerful for
implementing this
kind of feature.
For now, you're going to have
to do a little bit more work
on your side.
So when I've tried to implement
this stuff in the
past, I've just had to keep
track of the activities that
I've already seen, and just keep
paging past until I think
I've gotten most of them.
So it's a little bit fuzzy, and
there is the possibility
you're going to miss some.
But you can implement
this functionality.
And the way I've done once is,
I would page through a few
times every time I hit the API,
and then I would take the
activities that I've already
seen and stick them into a
bloom filter or a cache
of some kind.
Then, when I do the fetch
again, I take all the
activities that I grabbed,
compare them against that, and
then display them as output
from the application.
And this has the added benefit
of, if they've been updated, I
would display the updated
version too,
which is kind of cool.
So it can be implemented.
It requires a little extra
work on your side, and we
understand that adding that
filter would make it better.
So we'll look into doing that.
Thanks for the feedback.
Okey doke.
So I guess we're going to be
wrapping it up a couple
minutes early today.
Thanks for joining me
for the live coding.
And I have one quick
announcement to
make before we finish.
Up until now, we've been pretty
good about doing these
hangouts, these office
hours, every week.
We're actually going to be
cutting back a little bit,
starting sometime
in a few weeks.
So we'll be back next week, but
after that, we're probably
going to reduce our schedule to
about every other week or
twice a month.
We were doing this too, so that
we can produce smaller
amount but a higher quality
in content.
So we're going to focus a little
bit more time on what
we we're presenting, and make
sure it's always great.
And in the weeks we're not on
air, you can still reach us
via stack overflow,
our support forum,
our + page or yeah--
all of the existing channels.
We're still around.
We just won't be on air
quite as often.
That's all we have for today.
Thanks so much for watching.
And I'll see you guys all on
the forums and the + page.
Bye everyone.